shocking images from our southern border
show nearly 1
000 migrants surrendering to border
patrol as a new report reveals border
officials picked up more
unaccompanied minors than ever before
ever before with a record 19 000 in july
the numbers only fueling calls for vice
president harris to be fired as the
borders are including our next guest
former white house press secretary and
co-host of outnumbered kaylee mcananey
joins us now good morning kaylee
good morning ainsley good morning i mean
these numbers it's crazy these are
children that are coming across our
border without their parents
kamala harris where is she in all of
this
she's absent uh she is unserious about
this task of being the borders are it's
why it took her nearly a hundred days
to actually go to the border and when
she got there ainsley
she stood up and said we've made great
progress
how can you say that when there is a
21-year high
in encounters at the border a record
high as you note for the month of july
with unaccompanied minors this is a
disaster
and then she laughs about it she says
well i haven't been to europe when asked
about going to the border
she is failing at this task it's why she
has the lowest approval rating
of any vice president in the last half
century
so i want to also talk to you about uh
covet 19.
yesterday the president was trying to
address the flip-flopping of the cdc
and all of these ever-changing mandates
or guidance
dr michael osterholm he was a former
biden covet advisor
he's saying the cloth masks are
ineffective listen to this
know today that many of the face cloth
coverings that people wear are not very
effective in reducing any of the virus
movement in or out we need to talk about
better
masking we need to talk about in 95
respirators
here we go again what is what's your
reaction
here we go again the mass we've been
told to wear somehow now ineffective and
now we have to talk about n95
respirators
no thanks we're in a different stage of
the pandemic now we don't need mandates
we don't need masks uh people are
getting vaccinated but ainsley you know
i
i've got to say about the biden
messaging here i was in the
administration
with president trump president trump got
in front of that podium every day
flanked by a panoply of experts the cdc
dr fouch who was there dr berks and he
looked the american people in the eye
and took questions
for nearly an hour uh he made ppe
available to the biden administration he
made the vaccine available he made
therapeutics available
uh joe biden was handed a pretty good
hand of cards and he has squandered it
and this messaging is just
all over the map in a total disaster i
mean my gosh what are they going to
tell us next how does how is this going
to affect you and your family
yeah exactly what the mandates are are
clearly what's next you know you had the
cdc director go on with bret baer and
suggest that maybe we'd have a vaccine
mandate
then she went and cleaned that up but
look they're slowly tiptoeing in that
direction with joe biden yesterday
tacitly approving
the new york mandate that you have to be
vaccinated to eat in a restaurant this
is ridiculous it's orwellian it's
dictatorial but we are heading down that
road make no mistake he's tiptoeing
there